the Joe Rogan experience and then weird
you could see all the violence you want
like I watched John wick 3 last night I
finally finished it Jesus Christ 3/4 of
the way through I'm like how many
[ __ ] people have they killed this is
so ridiculous yeah it's just a murder
fest it's murder porn that's what it's
like isn't it kind of yeah but the crazy
thing is like that kind of violence is
unheard of but yet you don't show sex
like you could show people's brains
exploding but if you showed a girl's
[ __ ] and a penis going inside of it
people so one thing that doesn't hurt
anybody that everybody wants yeah yeah
her if the show like a vieira of home
with you know a brad pitt and give me a
hot woman actress Jamie you know hot
women actresses who's what Scarlett
Johansson okay Scarlett Johansson and
Brad Pitt have a sex scene and they
actually [ __ ] get after it
yeah and you see it you see your feet up
in the air maybe like what are we
watching oh yeah this is crazy but yet
you could see Brad Pitt spoiler alert if
you see that uh once upon a time in
Hollywood is that the name of it the
couldn't enter he beats a woman to death
smashing her face against a mantle of a
[ __ ] fireplace and you're like holy
[ __ ] and that's okay that's okay that's
okay that's five bucks short Scarlett
Johansson you saw her [ __ ] you'd be
like what I see her action this is crazy
get this up you should go to jail it's
weird things that everybody wants to do
like they all want sex
everybody likes sex everybody likes sex
but it's over you know beating some with
the death of their [ __ ] head off a
mantle I mean that's a daughter too
that's somebody's daughter [ __ ] more
weird bro we are weird yeah when you
look at it like that so weird so weird
you know how outrageous it would be if
Scarlett Johansson and Brad Pitt had an
actual sex scene in a movie they just
[ __ ] they said listen I like her she
likes me let's do this yeah and she's
like let's do
[ __ ] it I'm ready I'm ready to method
act that actually happened in a movie
called brown bunny it was a long time
ago there was a movie with Vincent Gallo
and there was an actress her name is
Chloe I forget how you say her name Sven
gee how do you say it
7g it's really good actress and he's a
really good actor and for whatever
reason they decided to do a sex scene
where she gives him a real [ __ ] yeah
and everybody who saw it in the theater
was angry all these critics were angry
they're like this is [ __ ] outrageous
this is Tarek and it really killed his
career I mean it killed her career a
little bit too I think definitely
derailed it but it [ __ ] killed his
career yeah everybody thought he's a
creep after that a creep like Ike rates
research a creep for something that
everybody's done right but meanwhile
everybody loves Keanu Reeves face and
eyeballs in the mouth he's cutting them
up and stabbing them and throwing them
off motorcycles like that's ok though
that's ok that's ok but Vincent Gallo
actually getting a legitimate [ __ ]
that's outrageous that guy should be
pulled out of Hollywood than ever done
is terrible who wants a [ __ ] yeah
it's weirdly we can't freaked out about
watching people do something that
everybody wants to do it's it's insane
very weird yeah insane engine yeah it's
super weird
that's funny what do you got Jaime he he
produced edited directed cinematography
of the video to do it okay in this scene
how about she actually sucks my dick for
all of it
no no really over let's do this
everybody would be like get the [ __ ] out
of here you probably had a film and not
let anybody know what was happening
until after it was over the crazy thing
is he talked her into it you imagine
she'd be like wait what the [ __ ] did you
say but he talked her into it and she
went with it but that would be fine but
you know there's a scene in Apocalypse
Now where there's a water buffalo and
they killed the water
flow with the machete they used a real
water buffalo and a real machete they
really killed the water buffalo for that
scene and now the people went nuts I bet
they went nuts and they go nuts now when
people find out about now they freak out
[Applause]